i i strongly suspect they have
legitimate grievances
you know democrat h.l menkin said
democracy is the
theory that the common people know what
they want and that they deserve to get
it good and hard
the idea that our elected officials if
they're elected legitimately
our elected officials actually reflect
who we are you always complain about
politicians all the politicians are a
reflection
of the dmos you know of the of the
people in a
in a democracy assuming that the
democracy
is functioning properly nicole wallace
on msnbc during the same interview
refuses to give michael steele this
point and specifically on the
on the case of election fraud or
an illegitimate election in 2020 she
says it's crazy and republicans have
no legitimate reason to be upset
the reality is there was no fraud there
are no ongoing appeals republicans are
saying gobblyguck
none of that is real it's just a man who
cannot come to grips with the fact that
he lost
decisively i understand the how what i
don't understand is the why because this
isn't just
you know an anti-elite world view
stick it to the mainstream media they're
out to get us this is a lie
it is a lie and i don't understand why
roy blunt goes along with the lie i
don't understand why asa hutchinson
says ah we're gonna let this play out
there's nothing to play out
judges appointed by democratic and
republican presidents have thrown every
lawsuit out
kelly lefler said that we have to let
the
investigation finish there is no
investigation there was no fraud no
widespread fraud no foreign conspiracy
there was no fraud
the recounts have turned up votes that
are
by and large exactly in line with the
vote on election day so
what i understand the how and i
understand that long-standing
institutional distrust i don't
understand the why why are republicans
willing to sell their soul for a big lie
i don't understand i don't understand
there's a lot that nicole wallace does
not understand she says there's no fraud
there's no fraud well just
repeating that silly phrase is not going
to make it so
they shut down the counting of the votes
on election night there was no reason
for that if everything was above
board they refused especially in in
philadelphia
they refused to allow republican poll
watchers in
even after there was a court order if
there was no fraud there was no reason
to do any of that
they invented in georgia some wild story
about a pipe bursting and that's why
they had to send all the pole counters
home
not true that turns out to have been a
complete lie they said they were going
to stop counting at 10 30. they sent the
poll watchers home they kept counting
until
past one in the morning if there was no
fraud there's no there's no reason to
to worry about that there were there are
whole thumb drives you know little
drives of votes that went missing
batches and batches thousands and
thousands
that showed up that had first gone
missing
if there was no fraud it's very
difficult to explain all of those votes
going missing
there were whole batches of votes that
came in with statistical improbabilities
impossibilities for joe biden 99.4
for biden and some drops there was no
fraud very difficult to explain that
now is that enough fraud to swing the
election i don't know the trump team has
not
apparently made that case yet in a way
that has convinced any judges
but don't sit there and tell me that
there's no evidence of fraud that's
completely ridiculous
the question is is it enough to swing
the election and even if it were
would the judges actually swing that
election
i love it when the left which by and
large does not believe in the existence
of the soul
they don't by and large they don't
believe in the existence of the
spiritual component of man they think
we're all just vulva owners
and owners of other appendages right
that we're not even spiritual creatures
they say you're selling your soul
you've gone over to the devil people who
don't believe in the devil
people who don't believe in the soul
tell us that
they don't understand what they're
saying and they certainly don't
understand what they don't understand
there was a hearing yesterday in arizona
on this question of fraud
matt brainard who's former data chief
and strategist for the trump campaign
presented his case for
what he viewed to be major anomalies
in the vote counting take a listen i
would say
there's two levels of confidence i have
okay the first level of confidence is
very and i am very confident that we get
very close to that number
when we take the uh residency issues
and then apply it to the other counties
for which we weren't able to obtain data
the second level of confidence is where
you take a number
of projection we go back out to low
activity analysis
and nco analysis which i'm not gonna get
in the weeds but these are basically
people telling us that they had votes
um that they didn't cast votes they were
cast their name
if you're comfortable projecting these
numbers um to the population that we
were trying to reach via phone that we
just
couldn't i think then you reach another
level of certainty that you're able to
bridge that gap
um so i i think that that i'm i have a
high degree of confidence that the
number of ballots that were cast that
should not have been cast the legal
ballots
surpasses the margin of victory as it
stands right now
and there's the line he's he's confident
this former data chief is confident that
the number of illegal ballots
surpasses the margin of victory for joe
biden does that mean
that joe biden won i don't know we need
we do need to be able to prove that you
know and
uh unfortunately judges are not
accepting these sorts of arguments right
now
and and time is running out for
president trump to prove that
now people who continue
such as myself who who refuse to concede
this election and who discourage
president trump from conceding the
election yet
and who say the process needs to play
out those those people who haven't given
in to the left yet
are being castigated as fanciful as
liars as irresponsible as not putting
the country first
give me a break give me a break nothing
about uh permitting
large evidence of corruption to go
away in the shadows and not be discussed
nothing about that is good for the
country
nothing about ignoring our
constitutional and legal processes
because the media want joe biden to be
called the president-elect
today before the electors vote nothing
about that is good for the country
and if there were political consequences
for having a spine
so be
[Music]
you